hi everyone it's jerry this is game one
from the 2021 world chess championship
match between jan napomnichi playing on
the white end
and three-time defending champion magnus
carlson time controls for this match are
two hours for your first 40 moves
and move forward you gain 60 minutes
and after move 61
you gain not only 15 minutes but also a
30 second increment
is implemented
so let's hop right to it see how this
opening phase went
we have on board arroyo lopez
here's a nice photo from the event
courtesy of nikki riga
one of the photographers
uh capturing the moment when jan is just
about ready to play bishop b5
now this opening phase neither player
really blinked we do get a sense of the
clock times how much time each is
spending on each of these moves
i have that on the right the first
moment i found interesting is right here
after
h3 this is where
well
before h3 let me point out that if c3 we
could
you know very well see carlson going for
the
marshall variation
of this opening
uh the marshall attack
gambit
but yeah no c3 instead the more standard
h3
and if black follows up with d6 we enter
more standard
waters let's say
uh we could then have the c3 knight a5
this
this sort of stuff happening
but
carlson at this stage uh
goes for an imbalanced position
and
goes hunting for the bishops basically
knight a5
and the cost connected with this is the
is a pawn
so there goes the e5 pawn but there goes
the light square bishop
extra pawn for white bishop pair for
black that's the imbalance bishop gets
on the main diagonal prior to d5 we
don't want to see any knight jumps into
c6 there's pressure on e4
it's defended d5 only now
e4 is difficult to maintain so it's
given up
why not recapture with the new piece and
in the process generate a mate threat
neither player
is blinking up until this point queen f3
defends offers a queen exchange
bishop d6 is it really healthy
to have that bishop on an open file
unprotected no
it's more secure on d6 it's adding
pressure to white's furthest advanced
piece
king f1
played pretty quick and it's not the
most natural looking move these guys
have seen this position before
um
what is king to f1 doing well let me
point out what one of the more natural
looking moves would be here
this seems pretty tempting oh let's
develop a piece and generate a threat
there's a problem with that and the
problem is queen takes knight black is
winning
what's the problem here well queen takes
bishop that would be mate
another variation would be
well if you take like this black takes
like that
black is up a minor piece
so you save this rook black saves the
bishop
you take the bishop take the rook black
is now up a rook
so
king f1 is now
preparing to play knight c3 next
black says hang on i'm going to defend
the bishop so
knight c3 wouldn't be a good idea again
because there would follow queen takes
knight
and black is winning out yet again
so after rook f to b8 what do we have
the queens are exchanged
how to recapture
with the knight that is definitely the
piece to recapture with because
it has an eye on the c2 pawn
it has an eye on the b4 square this is a
very sensitive point
in white's camp
these pawns are doubled this is a half
open file
but with this
a pawn no longer around to watch over
the b4 square
yeah this one is
sensitive
so
from here we have bishop d2
it's kind of like a half developing move
it's controlling the knight but more
importantly it's vacating the c1 square
if white
were to play knight c3 here black is
already winning after knight b4
that's how
that's how quickly this game could
basically end
how would white defend c2
there isn't a good solution if you play
your rook here this rook is officially
overloaded two jobs too many
you can take here or here
okay
bishop d2 first
like it's the c pawn rolling
why not create a duo why not be just a
moment away from creating an additional
pawn break with c4
it's not enough
black isn't quite ready to play that but
it
just a blink away
at some point that can
uh come about
ideally the more pawn breaks the better
for the player with the bishop pair
why not
open the position further
okay so the c pawn is contributing black
creates a duo with that grabbing some
queen side space
a voluntary retreat we have a lot of
maneuvering
in this game this is i think one of the
the first
uh instances of some maneuvering
yeah that knight on e5 it was
far advanced but do we really want to
have the responsibility of
defending
the knight isn't really going to be
connected with any other white piece
being on e5 so
a voluntary retreat it frees up the rook
on e1
so repositioning on the black end now
getting to the d file
knight c3
knight b4 ducking the knight exchange
and pressure on c2 rook e to c1
defending
the other rook on c8 and now are we
close to having c4 here that's what i
thought during
the live stream i was running on twitch
that
is not quite the case it's not working
out after knight to e2
another repositioning
move
uh black is not able to play c4 here
this is an important note
uh it may be tempting to break down the
queen side structure like this but white
would be winning
after
this what would black do
problem on b4 and c4
no good solution
c4 isn't working
more repositioning knight c6
bishop e3 this is one of the better
pieces by white this is also supporting
potential break with d4
knight e7
preparing to challenge the bishop one
way or the other f5 and d5 are pretty
appealing
bishop f4 is played now this this break
could have surfaced
but after knight f5
uh black would be getting
a position where it's two bishops versus
two knights so let's say something like
this
it holds it as about an equal-ish
uh position
no d4
with the knight on e7
this bishop is now
stuck
when
you're
fighting against the bishop pair you
almost always want to try and exchange
one of one of them off so
the bishop stuck no retreat squares with
the knight on e7
white jumps at this opportunity the dark
square bishop exchange will come about
in fact all bishops will be exchanged
here black giving up their light square
bishop to damage the king side structure
there goes the dark square bishops
this guy is no longer around to watch
over a6 so some defense is necessary
rook c6
mission accomplish you don't need to
defend c2 anymore
knight f5 with an ion d4
that's negated
but now d3 is a bit more sensitive
this needs to be watched over
it is currently by the night and when
you make a move like c3 you have to
run some calculation here you have to
know that well what if this defender
is deflected
now in this position we have black
playing knight h4 but if g5 is played
how is white following up
the knights attacked where should it go
should it go anywhere
it doesn't need to go anywhere rook 5
would be a a nice follow-up counter
attack against this knight preparing to
meet pawn takes knight with rook takes
knight
rook takes pawn rook takes pawn we'd be
tending towards a draw in this
rook specific end game
okay
no g5 no
trying to deflect the defender of d3
instead knight h4 pinpointing one of the
weaknesses on the king side there are
many weaknesses
on the white king side
so white still up this pawn not the
healthiest extra pawn in the world
but
has to
make some defensive moves white up a
pawn but black has pressure that's
that's where we stand right now
how to defend f3 rook e3
king f8
this is i believe freeing up this rook
to maybe
step up some you don't have to worry
about your back rank
there is not going to be any back rank
mate now with the king on f8
the more standard
move is
something like g6 producing a square for
the king to step up into
i think by not having the pawn on g6 you
keep open the option as black to maybe
at some point
have this rook come over to the g or h
files
right
not the g6 square right now but things
can change
can maybe question the knight first
maybe getting the h3 pawn at some stage
if that pawn falls this guy will run
so
king f8
still keeping additional options open
along the sixth rank is my
my sense here
all right
from here knight g2 this knight is pesky
the white knight has just fiend kettled
itself
black says no way i'm not allowing you
to exchange your fiancee knight
the rook is attacked pretty much forcing
the counter-attacking move as otherwise
the d-pawn would
fall black glues the knight in
doesn't need to go anywhere
knight e1 defending d3
and now more repositioning knight g7
another instance of a fiancee knight
square does it have in mind
e6
and from e6 maybe f4
okay
from here rook to e4
this is
preparing a pawn break
what pawn break is that
b4 so if black
were to
follow up with
knight to e6 here
b4 is going to be helpful
these guys will be exchanged
let's say
we have this capture and i just make a
quick passing move
eventually this pawn is able to get to
d4
i'm not sure about it being played right
now i don't see a great issue
with playing it right now maybe you want
to put this rook here and only then play
here
but
my point here is that getting in this
structure
means that you no longer have to babysit
the pawn on d3
this is a a solid pawn structure and in
the process you're even creating an
awesome outpost for the knight on d3
so
b4 is desirable for white
black interferes with this and gives the
rook a kick
f5 on board
the rook
falls back
i looked at
trying to maintain the rook on this
fourth rank still being in a position to
possibly get b4 in there and it doesn't
work out
if the rook goes to f4 or h5 well let me
point this one out first rook f4
ooh
that's gonna sting
all
all the black pawns cover
all fourth-ranked squares
that would hurt
and
if the rook went here this guy still
goes here and eventually this rook is
toast brook takes pawn king g8 where's
this guy going
you'd have to give the rook up for the
knight
all right
you can't stay on the fourth rank in
short
rook e3 it is
not just to any square
black
white needs to make sure he can offset a
black knight on f4 this is where the
knight is
this is what black is angling for a
knight on f4 so the rook defends d3
knight e6 once more the knight is being
cut out cannot allow the knight to get
to get to get into f4
from here we now have b4
and this
uh sets
uh napomnichi
basically back in his seat for some
minutes
uh he
he's under some pressure here and needs
to come up with
i believe uh
a good plan let's say
uh
the threat here is
to
well first of all
black putting pressure on c3 black
really wants to see this pawn move
a capture or a push i think this would
be worst
of all
worst of uh yeah
the poorer of the two
because it opens up the file and the
knight still has access to d4
if you push okay the knight just has
access to
this d4 square but that's that's
still pretty bad
you could get that b
maybe even land a fork
this guy shouldn't budge
and what's right around the corner
is rook to b8
a capture and then the b3 pawn is gonna
fall so
how to cope with this planned by black
well let's see what eon comes up with
currently down upon
he plays king to e2
is the king gonna be there in time to
defend the b-pawn let's find out rook b8
king d2
pawn takes pawn
pawn recaptures making sure this knight
does not have access to d4
but then there goes the b-pawn but
is that okay
it is
this is in my opinion
a
well not just my opinion this is
this was considered one of the best
lines
by the engine
to have this little king walk towards
the queen side what's happening here
white is giving back the pawn
ensuring the knight does not get to d4
and the white king now all of a sudden
plays a very useful
role very productive role of watching
over d3
watching over any entry points
and you'll also notice that because of
these exchanges along the b file there's
no b pawns and because there's no b
pawns these guys are split
and more vulnerable
it's true this guy is passed but it's
not really seen as an asset in this
environment
it has to
you know has to just be watched over for
right now
the white king is working the black king
is not
the black pieces are now on the on their
back foot they have to play a defensive
role that's the change that we're seeing
here this is these are some of the
things that you stare at uh
the evaluation just the number alone it
doesn't really
provide you with this
uh this information
white has released some pressure by
giving back the pawn
and
has an eye on a square of his own
for the knight
namely c4
as soon as b4 was played i could have
been pointing that out
c4 is a great home for this guy
just a couple moves away from getting
there
and when the knight is there it's hard
to imagine black can be any better
okay
first it's h4
it does negate any possibility of a
knight g5 jump
black improves the king
the rook gets out of the way so that the
white knight
can get to e3
it gets to e3
and then c4
and now black has to be careful
right we got a night jump here
this rook has a responsibility there's
pressure on the night
all the white pieces are doing very well
now that the white king is on that c2
square when it was on f1 just a little
bit ago it wasn't contribute it was not
a contributor but now it is and now
white is generating threats
how to defend we have in this position
rook to e7
which is
basically the offer of a draw
it's an implied draw offer because at
minimum
white has the possibility for a
repetition a
a perpetual attack let's just say
against this c6 rook
in the following way
knight e5
the rook only has these two it has to
defend the a6 pawn so
rook d6 was played the knight returns to
c4
the rook has no other option than to go
back to c6
and this is in fact
how the game ends
with a repetition
of position
game one
ending in a draw but a fighting
draw this was a very nice idea
that jan came up with
to bring that king to the queen side
give the pawn back
release some pressure and all of a
sudden black is the one who is on the
defensive and again
at the end of the day this night there's
no way
uh black can justify trying to
go for a win
or something or something like that with
the knight on c4 it's just a fantastic
piece i would say a best piece in this
final position so
let's have a look at
uh the tail of the tape on this one you
can see just how
accurate these guys were playing
uh right here
yeah it was only ever just a
tiny advantage for white
right around what is this move 22 bishop
f4 when
we had the bishops being exchanged it
dips down in in black's favor a little
bit but never really anything
significant
uh throughout these guys are playing
super accurate right out of the gates
uh
team white with an average centipede
loss of seven and team black average
70-pound loss of eight so
a nice start to this championship
uh we'll see how the rest of it goes
again it's a best of 14 so i'm looking
forward to
all of these games game two
uh will be happening before you know it
so
uh feel free as usual
to leave any feedback to this video i
encourage any uh comments in the comment
section below
i hope you enjoyed it and maybe took a
thing or two away
that's all for now take care bye
you